[Musica]
parliamo della paura del diverso e di
sue possibili origini circa un secolo fa
freud diventò una delle persone più
influenti del mondo dicendo di sostanza
una cosa abbastanza semplice noi esseri
umani siamo una specie animale per
quanto molto complessa frutto di
un'evoluzione quindi abbiamo un corpo
degli istinti in se questi istinti che
devono essere espressi in forme civili
vengono troppo compressi si hanno poi le
nevrosi disturbi mentali
chiediamoci se non ci sono naturalmente
la sessualità
oggi dopo un secolo ha trovato infinite
espressioni più libere per esprimersi ma
chiediamoci se non ci sono altri istinti
che invece non hanno ricevuto questo
allargamento del loro campo o
addirittura il cui campione di
espressione si è ristretto se per
esempio abbiamo un cane
notiamo che anche se vive in un
appartamento cittadino ha conservato un
istinto del territorio che ne è
dell'istinto del territorio della specie
homo sapiens nella nostra evoluzione
eravamo già homo sapiens quando siamo
passati da nomadi stanziali con
l'elezione dell'agricoltura ma anche nel
corso della storia fino all'inizio del
novecento e gli storici ci dicono che
l'individuo normale medio persino in
europa la stragrande maggioranza
conosceva 200 persone nella propria vita
questo non poneva grandi problemi di
spazio ne di diffidenza che naturalmente
si mette in moto e un altro istinto
necessario non possiamo fidarci di tutti
quando qualcuno entra nel nostro spazio
tra l'altro abbiamo visto da allora la
popolazione dall inizio novecento si è
moltiplicata per quasi otto volte no nel
secolo scorso
nell'ultimo secolo c'è stato un
urbanizzazione travolgente e dieci anni
fa le nazioni unite hanno comunicato che
la popolazione del mondo ea maggioranza
urbana e la sproporzione continua
aumentare perché masse immense
continuano a trasferirsi nelle città
perché offrono più opportunità anche se
offrono per esempio le i disturbi
mentali sono infinitamente più alti
nella vita cittadina
cosa succede nelle città noi incontriamo
non centinaia ma migliaia di persone se
usciamo non nella nostra vita ma ogni
giorno e se qualcuno va al lavoro con i
mezzi pubblici per esempio la
metropolitana
siamo costretti a stare con un altro
centinaio di persone così una cosa
piuttosto innaturale per il nostro
istinto del territorio notiamo tra
l'altro che quei famosi 200
corrispondono quasi esattamente a ciò
che le modernissime neuroscienze ci
dicono una funzione principale del
nostro cervello cioè il nostro cervello
è fatto per immagazzinare fino a 150
volte arrivando ai 200 comincia entrare
in confusione di più non li riconosce
questo significa dicono per esempio i
neuro scienziati che
i social stanno ingannando radicalmente
le nuove generazioni perché gli dicono
avrete migliaia di amici
il che dicono è assolutamente
impossibile a meno di non falsare
sfruttare completamente un concetto
importante come quella di amicizia
comunque noi siamo compressi per esempio
nei vagoni e i nostri istinti sono
violentati la nostra buona educazione
c'impedisce scopi di aggressività ma
sarebbe impossibile imporre anche agli
animali più intelligenti più vicini a
noi come gli scimpanzè di richiudersi in
100 in un vagone
tutto questo è notevolmente aggravato
in questo senso di disagio di diffidenza
negli ultimi tempi dal fatto che molte
delle persone con cui condividiamo lo
spazio sono improvvisamente doppiamente
sconosciuti cioè sono immigrati
il nostro era un paese di emigrazione
non esistevano sono diversi per colore a
pelle per lingua e purtroppo anche qui
gli studiosi degli istinti ci dicono a
un certo punto questa sovrapposizione
tra natura e cultura
gli istinti vengono ingannati e non li
riconoscono più come appartenenti alla
specie umana cioè scatta l'aggressività
che noi abbiamo verso le altre specie
facciamo un passaggio dal dagli istinti
dell'individuo ai grandi movimenti della
storia sappiamo che nel secolo scorso
hitler provocò una delle maggiori
catastrofi che si ricordino perché
propose come spiegazione semplicissima
di nuovo quasi animalesca istintiva alla
germania in uno stato di ansia senza
precedenti a causa della sconfitta della
prima guerra mondiale e successivamente
della grande
l'azione senza precedenti per cui non si
sapeva come si sarebbe vissuti al domani
la spiegazione che il paese stava
degenerando perché perdeva la sua
purezza razziale necessaria
oggi sappiamo che il concetto di razza
che si usava e anti scientifico e
accusava gli ebrei di complotto non
tentò ormai di dimostrare neanche
l'esistenza di questi complotti passò
direttamente alle leggi razziali
costruzione di campi di concentramento
poi di sterminio poi guerra questa
intolleranza anche delle diversità
minime e nota alla psicopatologia come
paranoia e il paranoico è una persona
così incapace di psicologia che non
riesce a riconoscere nessun errore
dentro di sé e quindi segue dei
meccanismi istintivi per cui visto che
l'errore esiste deve sempre puntare il
dito contro un autore del errore esterno
notiamo che a differenza di altre forme
di patologia mentale la schizofrenia la
depressione che escludono della società
la paranoia a questa particolarità
pericolosissima che in mano a persone
dotate di potere politico funge
addirittura invece non da esclusione ma
da moltiplicatore del loro potere in
momenti di ansietà collettiva
particolare e l'antropologia qui si dà
un suggerimento e cioè che in tutte le
società di nuovo a livello molto
semplice di reazioni cioè nelle società
tribali a uno stadio primario esistono
dei riti di questo tipo purificatori
diritto del capro espiatorio
cioè moltissime società tribali che
vivono che so io semplicemente di caccia
se un anno c'è poca selvaggina non si
chiedono come noi
qual è il motivo razionale per questa
assenza non cercano una spiegazione
magica si chiedono chi ha gettato il
malocchio identificano il portatore del
malocchio lo sacrificano e antropologia
e psicanalisi ci dicono effettivamente
ottengono per un tempo limitato un
sollievo funziona come psicoterapia
collettiva non molto diversamente da
come hitler o stalin una scala molto più
immensa ad additando il nemico razziale
o di classe ottenevano un certo consenso
proprio nella popolazione traumatizzata
dalle loro stesse politiche repressive
a questo punto passiamo al sì ai nostri
tempi e chiediamoci se abbiamo sempre
bisogno di spiegazioni razionali o con
tutti gli strumenti culturali di cui
disponiamo non potremmo diventare
effettivamente più ragionevoli in realtà
il progresso tecnico e scientifico non è
necessariamente seguito da un progresso
morale
sono 500 anni che abbiamo la stampa
eppure continuiamo ad accorgersi del
fatto che i mass media che ci mettono
sempre più informazioni a disposizione
alle volte ci offrono più verità
alle volte invece moltiplicano non la
verità ma la falsità con la fine del
secolo scorso è entrato in gioco anche
internet
altra passo immenso nel progresso
tecnico e tuttavia già dall'inizio è
stato studiato il cosiddetto paradosso
di internet e cioè se io voglio
diventare più competente in qualcosa
inter né mi dà informazioni crescenti
quindi il mio sapere cresce ma di nuovo
siamo umani fino a un certo limite
se voglio farlo crescere all'infinito
cresce la mia confusione dopo una certa
soglia
invece della vera competenza e negli
ultimissimi anni
a questo si è aggiunto anche l'uso dei
social i quali di nuovo ci danno il
grande vantaggio di arrivare a
moltissime persone tutte le direzioni
e tuttavia gli studi sui social ci
dicono che tendono tutti a privilegiare
messaggi particolarmente brevi i
messaggi brevi sono purtroppo più non
quelli che contengono degli studi e
delle spiegazioni
accurate ma le semplificazioni
aggressive e accusatorie cioè di nuovo
un puntare il dito e cercare il capro
espiatorio
tant'è vero che probabilmente saprete
che ci sono stati dei morti a causa di
questo in certi paesi sono stati postati
su facebook informazioni calunniose su
sette persone è la conseguenza sono
stati dei linciaggi poi il post falso
viene tolto ma intanto le persone sono
morte
se veniamo al nostro paese ea questi
tempi c'è una cosa che oggettiva di cui
abbiamo una paura che però potrà
scendere nel paranoico la paura
dell'attacco terrorista in sel fenomeno
assolutamente oggettivo
tuttavia anche in italia mentre ci sono
stati attacchi gravi in francia anche in
italia abbiamo molti casi di persone
ansiose che dicono da quando c'è il
terrorismo
io non esco più di casa
eppure se guardiamo alle statistiche il
terrorismo in italia non ha ancora fatto
vittime
il terrorismo islamico in realtà ci sono
state delle vittime ma della paura del
terrorismo quando a torino una folla è
fuggita calpestandosi per timore di un
attacco terrorista che non c'era stato
la persona che dice io non esco di casa
perché fuori potrebbe esserci un killer
non dice io non esco di casa perché c'è
un killer che si chiama inquinamento
atmosferico
eppure l'agenzia europea dell'ambiente
ci informa che fa più di 84 mila morti
all'anno in italia e quasi mezzo milione
ormai in europa continente pulito
vediamo finalmente questo diagramma che
rappresenta i principali paesi europei e
in essi la presenza di immigrati
musulmani che sono ovviamente quelli che
ci fanno paura perché fra di loro
possono nascondersi i radicali
terroristi la linea gialla indica la
loro percentuale reale quella grigia
indica quanto le inchieste dicono che il
pubblico crede sia la presenza dei
musulmani
la linea grigia vedete che è ampiamente
superiore al dato reale cioè c'è un
pericolo reale
ma c'è una paranoia che ancora più
grossa è in mezzo a questi dati
preoccupanti vediamo però una buona
notizia
la differenza tra dato reale è dato
fantasticato la paura immaginaria è
massima in ungheria dove si ritiene che
gli immigrati islamici siano ben 70
volte più di quanto sono in realtà cioè
tutto è per noi è minima invece in
francia e in germania pur essendo sempre
molto alta dove abitano milioni e
milioni di immigrati islamici e lavorano
insieme alla popolazione locale da tempo
questo significa in sostanza che la
miglior difesa contro una degenerazione
di una paura reale in una paura
paranoica sta nel conoscere chi è
diverso nel non puntare il dito ma
collaborare con lui e riconoscere che è
umano e quello che riguarda
l'inquinamento ambientale naturalmente
il dito che dovremmo cercare di non
puntare troppo fuori dovrebbero
segue grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]